hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play slender again
I've got a news crew in my room look
that's a news anchor lady and so um
they're here interviewing me for the
money that we raised on Saturday for
cancer Research Institute so thank you
guys so much I wouldn't have this
opportunity without you guys and this is
going to help raise awareness for
charity all around the world so I'm just
gonna play them slender because they
wanted to get an idea of what I do and
what I do is completely ridiculous so I
don't know what they're going to do with
it but anyway the objective of this game
is to find pages in the woods
while avoiding a monster it seems simple
but it's actually quite frightening when
you're not in a bright room with studio
lights on you go but either way I'm just
wandering around in the woods trying to
look for pages and I've actually played
this before and I think I just broke my
legs no I'm okay
and there are okay I spawned in a
completely different location from where
I was before but it's pretty sure that
there was a page in here AHA so I've got
one page that means the monster is about
to start killing me eight and when you
get all eight you die anyway because
this is just a beta to the game the
actual full game has a full story and
everything I've gotten two pages so far
I know where all there are so I
shouldn't be too difficult but either
way like I said to them earlier
there actually is someone standing
behind me and there's actually someone
standing behind you as well
anybody I don't remember this can't be
oh there it is okay I got three pages
now and then the music starts you all
can't hear but there's some very scary
music going on in my ears right now
what where is he I don't see him
sometimes when he's nearby
your screen will start to freak out
because you're basically on a camera and
you're watching around so things will
start to freak out after a while if he's
nearby
Bava hiding he's right daddy bad
we can't go a bingo okay got her
Jesus I'm okay I'm okay just run away
okay didn't expect that to happen
I got stuck and he was right there did
you see him saw did you I don't think
they can talk to me I think I'm surly on
my own okay hey buddy okay so there's
the same guy again here's a page just
got to grab it and go
he's actually kind of different
everything's a little bit different here
like everything is distributed
distributed differently I'm actually
kind of confused actually where I
started out I've never seen before so I
have no idea where I am or what I'm
doing okay I got five just need three
more and we'll be good go home I'm home
this is where I start out before but it
seems to be fun stuff okay I guess the
starting areas are fenced up or
something I have no idea but either way
only three more and I still need to go
inside the building I see you standing
behind that light very creepily I didn't
even know you were there
oh I'm glad you're having so much fun
where do I see you Mart
glad you all are having so much fun at
my expense where's the dingdong building
there it is okay so this one page in
here and then there's another page and
other way wherever it is and it is not
here I have no idea where in this
building it is hi
oh I died I didn't get all the pages so
anyway I'm not gonna give it another try
just wanted to give this quick look so
they know what I was doing and they
couldn't hear what I was hearing so they
probably just think I'm being ridiculous
here so thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos that I've done check out I don't
know if I'll be able to get the video of
this on the news to you but I'll try to
figure out a way so thank you so much
for watching thank you
thank you thank you cameraman guy and so
I will see you in the next video bye bye
rock rock
oh wait no this
Oh